Hello Freak bitches to hear about all those people dying from heroin overdoses
because there was a bad batch of heroin in like Ohio or something.
And like 41 people I've overdosed on like the same heroin or,
I did hear about that.
I did hear about it.
No.
Did you hear about that?
What,
how do you say that stuff?
Kratos him.
How'd he say it?
Keratome k.
How'd he say it?
Let's say you're probably close to a trout.
Them Kratom Kratom may be Kratom.
I don't know how to say it.
I've never said it,
but I've read about it a lot.
And uh,
it's,
uh,
a plant that helps people overcome opiate addiction apparently.
And the FDA just moved it to schedule one or they're going to move it to
schedule one or the DEA,
I should say.
I guess it's the Dea.
Right?
But it's,
it's a plant
and apparently it helps a lot of people that have a heroin addiction problems
and opiate addiction problems.
And even some people said it helps with marijuana,
not marijuana,
but a alcohol withdrawals,
like people,
alcoholics.
And they try to break free and get sober.
This stuff can help with that too.
I don't know enough about it.
You know,
I'm to have,
I'm going to have someone on to talk about it,
but it's just,
there's no need to make anything else illegal like this,
this thing where they're doing like what they're doing is they're behaving like
an archaic society.
They're not behaving like America 2016 they're behaving like the people who
enacted the very first sweeping psychedelic laws of 1970 they're behaving like
they behaved.
If you've got this plant,
this Kratom or how have you say it and it doesn't have any history of people
like dropping dead from it.
It's not like some threat to the communities.
It's not like this a terror that's sweeping the streets and it's ruining lives.
You're not hearing that.
All I'm hearing is it helps people with heroin addiction.
We all know how many people are addicted to heroin.
So the fact that they just want to step in and immediately not just make this
like a schedule two or schedule three or have some scientists come in and
testify about it and have some sort of public hearings where they discuss the
merits of keeping this drug legal and should this be regulated?
Should it be prescribed by doctors like reasonable adults would do if they
actually gave a fuck about each other,
but instead they have these fucking ridiculous amounts of power where they could
just step in and just make things illegal.
They have a ridiculous amount of power when it comes to legislating what we can
and can't do with our bodies because this is not something anybody's voting on
this kratom stuff.
So for the DEA to just step in and make that schedule one,
it's blasphemy.
Like what they're doing is a mat.
It's a,
it's such an abuse of the function of the office.
The idea of the office is you're supposed to be protecting people,
protect people from math prep,
protect people from bad shit.
Don't.
Don't let people come home to find their children,
uh,
that,
that have overdosed because someone gave them bath salts,
right?
That's,
that's what everybody wants from something like the Dea.
But they're so far reaching with their efforts that they step into all these
areas where we know you're full of shit.
Now he's stepped in these areas like marijuana,
or you're going to save people from pot.
Congratulations.
You've fucking cock blocker.
What are you going to do?
You're gonna say people from giggling or eating yummy food or having a good time
with their friends.
What are you going?
What are you,
what are you stopping?
These are,
this is not anything that we should ever,
not,
not anything we should ever ask for from our leaders in quotes,
and definitely not anything we should ever tolerate for no reason whatsoever.
There's no reason whatsoever why they would keep marijuana illegal.
There's no reason whatsoever whether it would make this kratom stuff scheduled
ones.
There's no fucking reasons.
Money.
It's,
it is.
It's a sure sign that it's a corrupt system.
If that Kratom stuff helps with alcohol withdrawals,
then you got to know that these big companies would,
why wouldn't they pitch them some money to be like,
Hey,
let's you don't want Mencken.
Even if they didn't do it blatantly,
even if they didn't do it blatantly,
if they're in tangled with each other,
you can best believe that if you are entangled with some sort of an alcohol
company,
you're going to do your best to maximize the profits of that alcohol company.
Right?
I mean it's just the way it is.
If you're entangled with some donor to some political campaign or some,
some,
you know like foundation that you run and they give millions of dollars,
like you guys having a little agreement going on there.
You don't have to even say it.
You don't have to have a written down.
You don't have to be stupid about it,
but it's pretty obvious.
If someone gives you millions of bucks there,
you know you guys are out,
you guys are doing business,
something's happening here.
You know you're going to do nice things for each other now.
And that's,
that's where a lot of this shit comes from.
Like the,
the fact that we,
the people,
the people that are supposed to be represented by these clowns can sit back and
just be frustrated and not do anything.
We could vote for it when it comes up in our states.
But federally it's a giant issue federally.
Federally is the real problem because there's a bunch of states now that made it
illegal,
including Washington fucking DC.
It's a bunch of states that have made pot legal there.
They're like,
look,
it's ridiculous.
Doesn't the scientists and fit?
And then they start taxing it and then they make unbelievable amounts of money
and then they have massive resurgences and their economy like you're seeing in
Colorado and now you're seeing in Seattle and Washington state as well.
What they're doing is they're,
they're being Tyron nickel like these,
these are,
this is not like reasonable people acting in a reasonable way out that they're
locking people up for a long time.
Oh my God.
There was this fucking thing the other day where they were comparing that kid
who raped the girl and what university was that.
It has got ridiculously short amount of time.
What's that?
You don't have a mic on Stanford.
Stanford?
Is that what it is?
That guy,
so they compared that guy too.
I'm sit some poor bastard that,
oh my God,
I think he got 30 years for growing pot.
Oh yeah.
Did you see that picture?
Did you see it?
Dude?
He was even longer than 30 years,
man.
It might've been.
It might've been like 30 to life or something,
but it's just the idea that you would lock that guy away for that long for
something so fucking innocuous.
We'll put it below little blank.
The law.
It's real simple.
We got a law or you don't want to break it.
Okay.
You take your consequences.
We're adults here.
We're all adults.
These laws are stupid.
We're being handicapped by these ancient systems,
these ancient systems of control.
They don't,
they're not valid anymore.
He can't just lock people up for pot.
It's stupid.
Here it is.
Lee.
Carol Brooker a 75 year old veteran serving a life sentence in prison without
parole for being caught growing three dozen marijuana plants behind my son's
house.
Wow.
Oh my God.
And it says,
hi,
I'm Brock Turner,
20 year old who raped a woman on campus.
I just got six months in prison.
I'm also promised that with good behavior,
that would be cut down to three months.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's already out.
And there's like a armed protestors outside of his house.
Oh my God.
I'm so rape before joints,
guys.
Yeah.
That's just crazy.
If you're going to rape a girl,
don't do it on a pile of marijuana plants.
That's what we learned.
That'd be a good plus three months.
Okay.